we have this insane system now where you
need health care you're the buyer I'm
the doctor I'm the seller of health care
and somebody else pays the bill who the
heck is gonna shop for price when
somebody else is paying the bill
across the country the healthcare debate
is heating up we all want high quality
affordable health care but how do we
achieve that goal should we bet on the
free market or the government one thing
we can all agree on is that healthcare
costs have gotten out of hand
soaring health care costs health care
costs are way too high if we do nothing
to slow these skyrocketing costs we will
eventually be spending more on Medicare
and Medicaid than every other government
program combined before we can talk
about reforms that will work we need to
understand why health care has become so
expensive my epiphany with health care
came in an unlikely place best by david
grater is a Canadian physician who
practices medicine in the States as well
as Canada he's the author of the cure
how capitalism can save American
healthcare if you go to Best Buy you're
surrounded by cutting-edge electronics
the funny thing is prices continue to
fall with time falling prices is
something we've come to expect in the US
when we look at the cost in terms of the
length of time an average worker must
work to afford things we see clearly
that everything from food to jeans to
electricity has gotten cheaper over time
5/6 of the American economy individual
choice and competition works
prices fall with time value Rises and
people are content why wouldn't it work
with health care in fact it's worked
with some forms of health care
dr. Robert Maloney is a pioneer in the
field of corrective eye surgery I
started doing LASIK in 1991 as part of
the original FDA trial so I've been
doing it for 18 years and I've done
about 50,000 procedures we talked to
doctor Maloney about what's happened in
the lasik industry since the procedure
became available in the early 90s prices
were about $2,500 an eye 2000 and 2500
dollars an eye and they stayed that way
for a year too but
and other centers started coming in and
the price went down down down down down
because of competition because a lot of
people wanted and a lot of doctors
wanted to offer the service and just
like computers and televisions LASIK has
gotten better as well as cheaper our
modern-day lasers are super smooth we
can measure the eyes in ways that
weren't even possible 20 years ago
so it's been this incredibly virtuous
cycle of improved technology greater
options and greater results so how
exactly is LASIK different from other
medical procedures insurance doesn't
cover LASIK and that makes the
experience completely different for the
patient the problem with our health
insurance industry is that it's burdened
by government regulations that create
perverse incentives for everyone
involved it's complicated and it's
confused and it's polluted by the tax
code the answer say proponents of
Obamacare is even more government more
regulations more subsidies and a law
mandating insurance coverage can their
plan work fortunately we don't have to
look any further than Massachusetts
which implemented Obamacare like reforms
in 2006 today Massachusetts residents
pay the highest premiums in the country
and worse MassHealth the state's
Medicaid program is rationing care
MassHealth denies 23.8% of claims a far
higher denial rate than private insurers
in Massachusetts there hasn't been a
government solution that's worked here
in terms of maintaining quality and
reducing cost so what's the market-based
alternative I think LASIK can act as a
model for health care reform the kind of
reform dr. Maloney is talking about
could be accomplished without creating
new government programs or increasing
taxes in fact a few simple policy
changes would increase choice and
competition and put us on a path toward
a health care system that is better more
accessible and more affordable
the first change has to do with the tax
code during World War 2 as a result of
wage controls employers began offering
health insurance as a way to compete for
workers a few years later employer
provided health insurance was made tax
exempt and that's why well into the 60s
70s and 80s employers who are often not
just health insurance but a whole lot of
health insurance not just a cover you if
god forbid you're stricken with cancer
but to cover you if you decide to go to
your physician and ask about what better
blood pressure management or ingrown
toenails no one in the right mind would
design a health care system that
operates like an all-you-can-eat buffet
let alone one where employers pick up
the tab but today 90% of non elderly
Americans have job based health
insurance and that's simply not fair you
want to leave your job because you want
to do photographer you want to do
freelance journalism you're gonna pay
for your health insurance in post tax
dollars you're really punished by the
system extending the tax exemption for
health care costs that individuals would
benefit the unemployed and the
self-employed and it would allow people
who currently have job based insurance
to choose from a much wider range of
insurance options
the second reform scale-back state
regulations and create a national market
for health insurance health insurance is
expensive in part because of regulations
like guaranteed-issue which forces
insurance companies to provide people
with insurance regardless of
pre-existing conditions from a distance
that seems great the problem is
insurance markets don't really work like
that
if we applied those standards to home
ownership insurance you'd be able to buy
your insurance after your house caught
fire doesn't make sense
mandated coverages in many states also
drive up costs and needlessly so why for
instance should teetotalers be forced to
pay for insurance that covers alcohol
abuse treatment one has to be very
cautious about the best of intentions
when it comes to regulations we need to
move in the opposite direction I think
make it possible for you to buy a
bare-bones plan to cross a shop across
state lines permitting people to buy out
of state health insurance would allow
people in heavily regulated states like
New Jersey to purchase more affordable
insurance plans from providers and
states with fewer regulation
the third idea promote health savings
accounts an affordable alternative to
traditional health insurance plans
combined with high deductible insurance
that covers serious medical problems
health savings accounts allow people to
set aside pre-tax dollars for routine
health care money that's not used as
rolled over and can ultimately be used
for retirement with health savings
accounts people would be empowered with
their own health dollars and as a result
they've asked the sort of questions we
don't ask where can I get better value
what our price is like and so on and so
on exactly by the way what we do there's
no mystery here for other basic needs
like food clothing and shelter and
here's the kicker
once consumers are back in the driver's
seat health care providers will have to
offer better service at lower prices in
order to survive just like lasik
surgeons with lasik because people are
paying their own money they're very
sensitive to their experience does a
doctor make me way does he answer all my
questions do I get a great result if
there's a problem I'm out of there these
reforms are just a starting point the
Federal Drug Administration Medicare and
Medicaid all have serious problems that
deserve attention but make no mistake
about it we're at a turning point in
American history that would suggest we
look not to Britain Friday is not to
Canada Fridays but let's look to the
other five strips of the economy where
we have individual choice and
competition as guiding principles and
people are satisfied we've probably seen
ads for hair transplants where they
advertise the price how much it cost per
hair and there's a really vibrant
competitive market driving the price
down for for hair transplants I imagine
the same thing happening for routine
colonoscopies routine mammograms my just
routine checkups my guiding principle is
and always has been that consumers do
better when there's choice and
competition that's how the market works
mr. president I couldn't have said it
better myself for reason TV I'm Nicolas
you